I always wondered when I'm like when you
get to the stream like is that is it
weird that they know our health results
I'm like because I I told my chat too
I'm like whatever I mean I did a video
last year yeah I wondered I'm like is it
weird that we're making content out of
this maybe a little weird maybe a little
weird but yeah sure sure it was better
than last year it was it was actually
wow
it's working I I actually improved in
like everything I almost everything I
got to be in was like moved up to an A
and I remember last year I got like a C3
for my urine which oh [ __ ] that's right
I don't know what the [ __ ] I did I was
like pissing wrong uh this year got
upgraded to an A so I'm like okay
urine man I haven't got my results back
but uh mine has been the exact same for
the past three years yeah mine's
probably gonna be the same like Connor
you're the perfect specimen of a human
being but but what's going on with that
cholesterol we've got to sort that out
it was a little lower this year though
but again like all this [ __ ] means
nothing it's like they're like oh this
is what your HG slash L is I'm like can
you can you [ __ ] tell me what that
means also not to mention it's kind of
unfair for like people like us because
the they base that ranking mostly on
like the Japanese average yeah dude when
they measure my waist I'm like bro I got
a cake down there what are you like of
course it's not gonna be like yeah I'm
gonna come back fat yeah like because I
remember last year they were like oh
your uh your waistline is a little bit
wider than uh you know average and I'm
like no I'm just bigger than the average
Japanese person they're just going fat
okay is that what you want to say just
gonna be fat no it's it's just say it
yeah it's it's called natural insulation
and it's great in the winter I'm carb
loading okay
stocking up for the winter yeah I
remember when I when I was I think I got
that Health checkup uh in December dude
I remember I felt so I I was like this
the one person who stood out the most I
walked in wearing my drip jacket and I
just and I just sat down in this thing
between like 20 other Japanese
businessmen in suits and I'm just there
in my grip jacket yeah like number 22
I'm like it's me
just walking through these dudes and
they were just like you have the health
check I'm like
saw this
results it just says alpha male
dude I gold splitted the circuit this
year though I went through everything so
goddamn oh yeah there's like nobody
there yeah so I just went through
everything like I was in I had done like
uh it's crazy right Japan you do like
you do an x-ray you do a blood pressure
you do uh weight and height test you do
uh blooded
um uh injection no uh [ __ ] uh odd
sample yeah uh hearing listening test
the doctor consultation uh waste and
kind of I guess waste and then uh and
then they do like the heart cardio kind
of cardio put like Electro things on
your heart and they test it all that in
like 15 to 20 minutes like that I
actually like I don't know maybe they
changed it up on the day that I did it
but like they did it in like a
completely different order so I so
normally it's like the X-ray first right
yeah yeah I did the cardio thing first I
guess it depends on like yeah so I was
like oh are we is this like a new speed
run straight
[Music]
five to six of vials of blood when they
take your blood as well
it's like what no it's like it's like
two or three one no no they do like two
or three what I'm looking I'm like it's
like one or two tops for me no no they
they take at least three really yeah but
they do it so fast that you don't even
notice because they do it mid
conversation they're like oh does it
hurt
yeah and then they've replaced it with a
new vial before me yeah because I I like
I think we talked about this before but
I can't look when they're taking the
blood
um so then you know I'm having this
conversation with the nurse or whatever
who's obviously trying to keep my mind
off it and then I look back and there's
like a basket full of just like my
[ __ ] blood oh like five vials I don't
know if you hit 30 the the like they
make you do more tests but I'm like
Jesus Christ that was in my body the
lady's like this is my Personal
Collection she's just like
this
I've been meaning to test some fine
timelines
a country's blood stalked up on my
shelves oh my God yeah but I mean the
health is it's a good way to keep you on
your keep you on your toes yeah if you
get to I think 40 you have to do a
mandatory colonoscopy yeah yes this is
not [ __ ] wild yeah that seems like
I'm just not gonna make it a 40. I'm
chill I'm not I'm quitting I'm out he
hits a 39 you're like I'm out I
understand why we're doing it and I
understand the risks of not having a
colonoscopy and I'm good with that today
today are nests the size you though no
no not in Japan no in Japan a lot of
common procedures in the US where you
would get anesthesia yeah you don't in
Japan so so what you just awake while
they shove a camera up your ass yeah
[ __ ]
I'm good family I'm out of 39. you ask
people jokes on you some of them you
like that [ __ ] yeah
because I'm ready because like in Japan
are you people okay with something and
you make it just make emojis the thing
is
guaranteed there's some 40 year old
salary man that's just like it's time
for my yearly Health checkup oh boys I
couldn't sleep last night because I was
so excited
he's like do you mind lights candle
they go
like that when you miss it oh yeah
oh yeah so there's no way I I they must
have it like
yeah yeah they just like play like a
thing like a recording of a woman it's
concerning though if you look up like uh
or ask people who've had certain
surgeries in Japan and if you have the
exact same surgery in like the us or
Europe you you would you would have some
kind of pain medicine in Japan it's only
like no yeah for certain things that you
would in other countries they're trying
to bring super [ __ ] concerning you're
like I would like to not feel this
please yeah it's like it's the only time
when Japan is like you're an alpha male
right you can take it it's strange
yeah at least obviously you don't want
to use super strong pain kills but you
don't have to but there's some some
situation you're like please I beg of
thee please give me something I don't
want to feel this yeah I am begging you
like I literally don't have an option to
not do this it's mandatory and also I
guess uh Japan doesn't you know the over
the counter pain medicines also super
weak which is probably a better thing uh
because in America the stuff you can get
is pretty strong yeah I think they do
that mostly I think I remember reading
it up I think they do that mostly
because it's for the older generation
who like you know their body can't take
as much stronger medicine but still it's
like because I remember you know I had
to buy some pain medicine when I had the
stomach flu right and I and I went to
the pharmacy to get some over the
counter and I was like give me your
strongest [ __ ] I am dying right now and
she was like all right here you go and I
looked at the packet and it was like
take three times a day uh one time take
seven tablets and I'm like
I'm just like [ __ ] chowing down
yeah because I know it's uh the first
time I got sick in Japan yeah uh because
yeah I I remember that that one time uh
we had karaoke together and like we all
got ill or something like that
yeah I remember we had like I had it was
a 10-day trip and had one day of karaoke
and uh with Joey and then the rest of
the trip was just me being ill in bed
with Sydney in my Airbnb and that was my
trip to Japan but I remember like good
times I thought for how expensive the
over-the-counter medicine was because
you can get like paracetamol Lem sip you
know Tylenol in England and America yeah
pretty cheap uh in here I remember like
this one this one week I spent like a
hundred bucks at least for just like a
week's worth of over-the-counter
medicine and it was like weakest [ __ ] it
it did nothing give me the real [ __ ]
yeah give me the real [ __ ] dark but but
I think that's the thing it's like I
don't know if it's like a tactic or
whatever but like I think that's why a
lot of Japanese people just don't even
bother going to the over-the-counter
stuff they just go see a doctor to get
like the actual proper stuff because
again like when I had the flu and like
the pain medicine like the seven [ __ ]
the 21 tablets a day was just like not
working for me I was like yeah all right
doc I I like this shit's not working for
me give me the actual good stuff yeah uh
and he gave me just one give me the good
stuff and he gave me one which was just
like one tablet three times a day and
that worked a million times better than
the over-the-counter stuff and it and it
cost less yeah and I was like what the
[ __ ] am I doing buying this over the
counter [ __ ] that doesn't work it's over
the counter [ __ ] you you pay like 20
bucks for one box and it lasts you like
a day because you're taking five pills
oh like they they recommend like before
and after uh before every meal take five
tablets I'm like there's only [ __ ] 10
tablets in this box what are you talking
about you know that you know that like
stereotype of like you know like old
folks homes where yeah you know they
have like the tablets thing what what's
it like in Japan it's just like he's
he's your cereal bowl of tablets today
man
yeah he's like how many [ __ ] tablets
are these old people I never buy
medicine here I can't take most of it
anyways because the yeah my blood oh
yeah yeah I shouldn't even bother
because I mean you're saving money yeah
I can't read this [ __ ] anyway so I don't
even know so I just don't bother and I'm
like I'm dying I'm like it's fine I'll
be fine I remember after like my first
few months of living in Japan uh the
next time I went back to England I'm
like Mom just let me go to Tesco's let
me stock up on all of the [ __ ] let me
stock up on all of the over-the-counter
medicines and I I remember I didn't
realize that there was a limit to how
much like limb sip you can oh yeah I
mean you almost have to be really
careful because some over-the-counter
stuff in the US and the UK uh it most
certainly cannot bring into Japan oh
yeah you're getting a lot of trouble if
you do yeah um so please before you
bring any medicine into Japan or any
country you just make sure that you're
allowed to yeah uh generally really weak
over-the-counter stuff is normally fine
yeah yeah because because I I wanted to
stock up on like paracetamol and Tylenol
yeah stuff like that well paracetamol is
a generic drug and you can get in Japan
as well you can get that in Japan but
it's it doesn't work
something I think it's called yeah
there's a generic name yeah it even
doesn't say on the box it's like it's
paracetamol no it's like a different
name yeah yeah yeah it's uh it was just
like a lot weaker and a lot more
expensive so I was like [ __ ] it I'll
just like buy uh buy some blem soup buy
some paracetamol to bring into the
country so I have like this medicine box
in my home that I can always rely on uh
and I remember going to the co-op to buy
like to buy like all of these different
boxes of paracetamol and they're like
what what are you uh what are you doing
here you like are you like dating to
kids or something what's going on here
because you want some drugs
I don't like no sir you don't understand
I'm just going to Japan
I'm sure that helped clear enough it's
like of course all right okay I think
like a generic box because of
paracetamol it's like it's like in in
like US Dollars it's like 50 cents 40
cents really super cheap damn that's
really cheap it's generic like you can
get it anywhere and a lot of stores sell
it in Japan it's like [ __ ] 15 bucks
yeah which is expensive it's ridiculous
but a bowl of ram it's like five yeah so
you can have five bowls of ramen or we
cash painkillers yeah like paracetamol
in in Japanese in Japanese it's like
another difficult vitamin or something
or something like that yeah it's [ __ ]
cold all right we are not MediCal
experts please do not listen to any of
our medical advice and please make sure
that you ask a professional before
you're Consulting for your medical
advice ask a doctor which we are not
honestly like my like like genuinely my
my advice of like if you're coming to
Japan and you get sick is that like well
obviously first get like you know travel
insurance and [ __ ] and just like go see
a doctor because like for one you're
gonna get what you need and also for in
a lot of ways it is cheaper and just
better in my opinion and also like a lot
of those these like you know General
Practitioners like they don't take that
much time out of your day like when I
went to go to the hospital it literally
took me like 20 minutes yeah the one
thing that is good about Tran is they
are pretty quick yeah you don't really
sit around like in the UK you can be
sitting there for a long time waiting
it's pretty sure yeah I was only around
for like 20 minutes and like the doctor
checked me out for like you know a
couple of minutes and was just like yep
he's he's a drugs it's either good or
bad
it's like hey dog you're fine [ __ ] off
yeah uh sure drugs drugs drugs
I love drugs